wir kommen jetzt zu jemandem der uns
eine legende geworden
absolut brummi brian bekanntgeworden
vereine sagt er das ist ein risiko das
sich entspannt bin unterwegs in der zone
also er hatte einen schönen abend der
brummi brian und ganz viele menschen sie
sehen selbst sind wirklich fan von
seiner offenen und ehrlichen worten
dafür deshalb klare kante zeigt und
seiner wut aber auch seine euphorie für
den gestrigen abend so einen freien lauf
lässt und ganz viele menschen wurden auf
ihn aufmerksam nicht nur sie nein auch
echte prominente und die haben für ihn
jetzt auch ein ganz besonderes angebot
schauen sie hier liebe bildserie ist
gespielt und ich habe mal gesehen auf
die dog
der general war bekloppt der promi brian
hat mark dampf abgelassen erst wenige
tage zuvor griechische mit seiner
freundin ergriff also spaß gehabt und
dann gut ohne ende so jetzt weiß ich es
versucht hat genug von seiner freundin
weil die den traktoren spielwaren oder
wegen die klimaaktivisten auf jeden fall
der typ ist erkannte privaten lied für
die brummi bryan am ballermann da sehe
ich die aber ich habe keine handynummer
könnt ihr den kontakt zu promi kein
hersteller machte hüftgold in kleinen
sorgen über zum beispiel die hupen
seiner freundin open gegen den
klimawandel oder einfach nur böse
bleiben hast du vollkommen aus jetzt
machen wir mal
er schützt das vokabular geht richtig
viel her also das ist alles was ein hit
so braucht aber hat auch der beinahe
alles was ein hit so braucht hat er
alles um am ballermann so richtig
durchzustarten
man ist nur einmal im jahr aber der
ballermann wenn man ja dort das ist ja
jeden tag der wollen wieder jetzt fallen
es geht wieder los in eine gewisse
kondition das kann nicht jeder wir haben
brian jahr getestet ob er bereit ist für
den ballermann und ihn auch den ein oder
anderen tipp gegeben für sein neues
leben rufen alle hey ich bin rein
ihr kennt mich ja ich werde euer neuer
star moment moment brian so in dem
ausschnitt wirst du garantiert kein mal
ist da unterschätzen wir den ballermann
nicht deshalb bleiben wir dich jetzt
erstmal ordentlich ein okay okay
[Applaus]
sie spielt darin heißen kein superheld
ich bin ein fußballprofi
nein
mobil
das gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
haben auch sie fällt mit der alles
komplette
auflage bin ich ehrlich und erfasst bei
vielzahl an stimmen deine spuren im sand
findet ihr meine aus
zugänglich war eigentlich das auch noch
so gut wie findet er sein outfit in
ordnung ist oder sich da wohl kommen ja
geil ich erkenne ich wieder anfangen
muss ich wohl
ein bisschen naja die paradies bogen
gefragt bist du
bist meine freundin na hallo wir sind
der partner
also alles super wissens gebracht mich
und dass tiger schon
und die schuhe
freund ist zwar vielleicht noch nicht
mallorca aber sandes sand würde ich
sagen und was ist da ganz wichtig
beim blau oder pink
jetzt
keine schule ging
[Applaus]
nein
du hast ein geiles outfit du bist
trinkfest und textsicher eigentlich
können wir dich so einen finger stecken
das wird ja bis sie sich sicher nicht
auskommt was er kann nicht so wahnsinnig
gut singen also check mehr brauchen das
funktionale outfit steht und er kann
einmal trinken ich weiß nicht ich glaube
mehr machen also
würde ich noch sehen morgen hier auch
immer trainer der gohrsmühle morgen mit
promi brian das verfolgen wir hierbei
bleibt natürlich weiter